تنتشر سجادة القنب عبر
سهل البقاع في لبنان محصولًا محظورًا ،
لكن ربما لم يعد الأمر طويلاً ،
تفكر الحكومة في إضفاء الشرعية على
زراعة الماريجوانا للأغراض الطبية
إلى آذان هذا
المزارع الذي طلب ألا نكشف عن
هويته فكرة داو مطر ولكن في
الحقيقة أي شيء.  جزء مني يقوم بدوريات صغيرة
مني ، يظهر لنا حول الحقول وهو
يغني بمديح نبات
نما المزارعون في هذه التربة الحمراء لأجيال ،
يا آنسة ماهد ، الطريق لقتل قناة ماريلا ،
يا آنسة ، قطعت
طريق هايدي ماشية بودرو منخفض
هايدل  مادورو يا علي
مارتي إميرا فويلا نظام آخر مقاوم للسيجار انظر الآن
أترك سيجارًا وأنا أعرف صديقي فيني
د.  فيل هاي هيلاري
تزداد صعوبة زراعة محاصيل أخرى مثل التبغ والبطاطس حيث
يصبح المناخ هنا أكثر جفافاً في ظل
هذه الظروف الصعبة.
حقيقة الاقتصاد المتعثر هي أن الحشيش
هو المحصول الأكثر منطقية للنمو في هذه
المنطقة ، فهو يتطلب القليل جدًا
من المدخلات مثل المياه والأسمدة
ولا يستخدمون أي مبيدات حشرية وكما
سيخبرك المزارعون أن الأرباح
مرتفعة إلى حد ما بينما  بعض
العناصر المحافظة تعارض أي شكل من أشكال التقنين.
حول الفوائد التي تعود على
بلد مثقل بالديون يمكن أن يوفر
حوالي أربعمائة مليون إلى 800
مليون دولار  عائدات
البلد كحل للمشاكل المالية
قد يكون العشب اللبناني أكثر خضرة ، لكن
الناشط جينو تيدي يشعر بالقلق من
أن العديد من مستخدمي الترفيه في البلاد لن
يستفيدوا من هذه الضجة ، لذا فالطريقة الآن
هي أنه إذا قاموا بإضفاء الشرعية على التصدير
للأغراض الطبية  سيبقى
الوضع نفسه في قانون العدالة الجنائية
في لبنان مما يعني أن الشيء الذي
قد تجني منه الحكومة الكثير من
الأموال لا يزال غير قانوني بالنسبة
للسكان المحليين وما زالوا يواجهون مشاكل
بسببه ولكن بالنسبة للعديد من الأشخاص الآخرين تشم رائحة هذه البراعم
مثل نقود بن ويتمان CNN في
البقاع لبنان